how you doing guys today we have 2014
for F150 and we're going to create a new
key let's
start so I'm going to use a lei fo38 it
have eight Cuts but the door have only
six pins so I only need to pick from
wafer number one until wafer number
six uh by the way if you like those
videos please subscribe so you can see
our daily videos basically every wafer
that I feel is spring I don't need to
pick I can skip it so I'm going to go to
the next one until I find one that needs
to be picked that it's not
springy uh and every binding pin I need
to uh
[Music]
pick
after the lock is picked I'm going to
decode each position and I'm going to
use uh my software which is insta code
and it's on my phone so every uh
position I need to push on the lifter
until it stops and then I know the
digits I'm going to open my app insta
code
live I'm going to go to uh search by
vehicle and I'm going to go to
[Music]
Ford I'm going to go based on a year
making model so Ford
F-150 from 2010 to
2014 and I'm going to put the first six
digits that I got from the door and it's
going to give me based on those six
digits the option for the extra two for
the ignition based on the
database now I'm going to use the SEC E9
key machine I'm going to put a age uh 92
880 bit key and I'm going to look for
age 75 which is the blade number and I'm
going to put all of those digits that I
got from insta code and will hit
[Music]
cut after we finish cutting we're going
to take the key to the car and make sure
that it turns and if everything is good
we're going to start the
[Music]
programming work smoothly on the
door first thing I'm going to do I'm
going to take the key and I'm going to
put the key in the own position without
trying to start uh just to make all the
lights come up I'm going to use uh otel
IQ a20 it's a key programmer it's an old
version but it's very good for those
Fords I'm going to connect the OBD under
the steering column let it
start I'm going to hit
okay I'm going to go hit okay to Key
Program I'm going to go to Ford by
vehicle I'm going to find F
serus and I'm going to go to
2014 and hit a key key and uh uh it's
going to the
system it's going to tell me to turn the
ignition on I already turned it on I'm
going to read the amount of keys in the
memory and now I'm going to add a key
tells me to leave the ignition on and
it's going to take about 10 minutes so
I'm going to leave it here um waiting
for 10 minutes in the meanwhile I'm
going to check that uh the car lights
and the AC that everything is off I
don't want to drain the battery and
we'll get back when it finish uh
[Music]
counting when it finished counting uh
it's not going to show you anything on
the on this computer but you know if it
finish everything um it should start the
car and it should in if everything was
done right um the car should start let's
listen
[Music]
thank you very much please like And
subscribe if you have any questions let
me know everything works nice and easy
thank you for
[Music]
watching